Good afternoon, Thank you very much to the
media. Welcome,
we are going to begin this
press appearance after the meeting between
the heads of state and government and the
president of the European commission on
the h2med project, the president has the floor
wonderlayer Thank you very
Manuel  by Antonio
Pedro
inpotent
Game changer for europe
already in your 2020 central
[Music]
participation
of France and president of the Spanish government
with this step we are excited
in Portugal and Spain
a corridor exclusively dedicated
significantly a paradigm because
simply
importers and re-exporters of energy
and for our own density with zoom of the
peninsula we have the capacity to
reinforce its energy fat in Europe
and it is a place less
important to enjoy we can disclose the
routers and spots of origin of that energy
Tell me about diversity
and we can give this contribution
to  all of Europe and also thank
the obstacles  the
between Spain and France
immediately
like three countries that know how to buy each
other But give it a whole of Europe And it is
that this Spanish spirit
[Music]
electrification of continuity
technology
[Music]
connection
that the victim
of a land
in the first place to  the
media for attending this
joint appearance and
first of all thanking the Alicante hospitality
of the people of Alicante in this
luminous city that hosts a very
important Summit for all the
Mediterranean countries we are going to talk logically
about these interconnections of the
energy response  and many other areas to
which we will also be able to respond
in the appearance that we make at the end
of the Summit, I would also like to thank
all the
officials of the European Commission of
this important agency that is
located here in the city of Alicante for their hospitality.
team and of course your host the
president of the european commission  He
has given us this space to be
able to appear and celebrate this
important meeting that, as
Prime Minister Costa has rightly said, is an
example of the cooperation of three
countries, France, Portugal and Spain, together
with the common government that we have, the
European government, the Commission.  European
Union we give a supportive response committed
to all the aspects that the
President of the French Republic has said about
this energy crisis. Well, this
energy interconnection has been baptized,
as you know, with the h2med, but
I also think that the
two interconnections that are made explicit in the first place must be made visible.
place the one that takes place between
Portugal and Spain and therefore Celta and the
second between Spain and France
through Barcelona and Marseille beard as you know
on October 20
both the President of the
French Republic the Prime Minister of the
Portuguese Republic and I  we did not
meet at the embassy precisely of
the French government in Brussels to  Before
the Autumn Council to agree to
work together to
launch a green energy corridor
linking the Iberian Peninsula with the
French city of Marseille so
that it could be connected to the rest of
Europe with that what we were
doing Well I believe that taking a step
forward to unblock an
energy interconnection project between France and
the Iberian Peninsula is even more necessary
than ever after Putin's war
in Ukraine and obviously we are not only
talking about hydrogen but
also as it comes Remembering the First
Minister of the Portuguese Republic,
also for electrical interconnections
, we agreed to meet again on that date
a little before
the Met 9 Summit here in Alicante to
examine the progress and
definitively promote this project,
specifying financing deadlines and
details for its execution and after  more than
a month of intense work by
the technical teams and also  as well as the
ministers involved,
whom I would like to once again thank, together
with the commission team, for all the
intense work they have put in
during these 30 days. Today we can
already present the main lines and
objectives of this project. The
h2 Med project has  two fundamental parts or routes
on the one hand, as I said
before from Portugal Spain specifically
from Celurico Daveira to Zamora and on the
other the route from Spain France
through the Mediterranean from Barcelona
to Marseille with this corridor I think we
reiterate a double commitment that I
would like  underline today here in alicante
in the first place we are reinforcing
energy security
the strategic autonomy of the European
Union at a time when it is
essential that we Europeans show
solidarity to reduce the
energy dependence of countries that right now
are using energy as a
blackmail tool  To the whole of
the European Union in its support for UCR  ania
And secondly, we reaffirm something that
President Macron has said and that
seems fundamental to me, we are reaffirming
the determination of the European Union with
climate neutrality, which has
hydrogen as its touchstone. My Country
Spain is fully
committed and is aware of  This has
already designed a
hydrogen roadmap in yet another example of the
will of the executive of our
commitment to the objectives of the
ecological transition Spain also wants to
lead together with Portugal and
France The commitment to this
energy transition we are already leading the
development  of renewable energies we are going
to be we want to aspire to be a
benchmark not only in Europe but
also worldwide in the field of
hydrogen and Allow me to highlight several
relevant data of this important
project it will be the first major
hydrogen corridor in the European
Union that is what  that we are
presenting today in Alicante the first
great runner of the  hydrogen from the European
Union the h2med that will be operational at the
end of this decade will be able to transport,
as the president of the commission has said,
10% of the hydrogen consumption
of the union by the year 2030, around
2 million tons per year.
Estimates
are obviously preliminary and I would like to be prudent.
Consequently, in this regard, the cost
could be around 2,500 million euros.
We will continue working tirelessly
to start up this
infrastructure. The first milestone will be the
presentation as a project of
common interest before December 15.
The three governments are going to do it. Thus,
as the president said, we are going
to opt for European financing instruments,
especially the mechanism to
connect Europe, which allows
up to 50% of the project to
be subsidized.
to have a
vital infrastructure for Europe, not
only for the tr  It
is fully finalized and
operational in 2030 and I want to
reiterate my gratitude to the
president of the European Commission, dear
Úrsula, for attending this meeting for
hosting us in this important agency, it is
a sign of the
European Commission's commitment to this project.
so necessary for the
diversification of energy sources
and for the energy supply
of each and every one of the countries of the
Union in fact it is significant as I
said before that we meet today in the
uipo the office of intellectual property
of the Union  European Union that symbolizes the
European spirit that permeates this
initiative and likewise I want to thank
the participation, the empathy, the
commitment, the solidarity and the will
to agree from the President of the
French Republic, Manuel Macron, the
Prime Minister of the Portuguese Republic,
Antonio Costa, dear
Emmanuel and Antonio, Muchísimas  thank you
for contributing to the definitive impulse to
In conclusion, as you can see, this project, which is so necessary for Europe, has
been a productive meeting with
concrete results that will
allow our technical teams to continue
working at maximum performance. I believe
that the commitment to this corridor is
undoubtedly excellent news for France,
for Portugal and  For Spain, the fact that our
countries can add their strengths to their
ability to innovate their talent in a
project of this magnitude is a source of pride for me as
President of the Government of Spain,
and it is also a great
responsibility for what affects us.
But I also believe that it is
fundamentally  extraordinary
news for Europe for Europe as a
whole because this great
energy corridor will give greater security and
even stronger strategic autonomy To the
whole of the European Union So
thank you very much to the three of you thank you to
the media and above all
thank you  to the team and Alicante for
hosting us in this important Summit